[Musique]
nous sommes dans le métro sur la ligne
châtelet mairie des lilas banal direz
vous le métro nul utilisons tous les
jours nous le connaissons que trop
croyez vous depuis hier cette ligne
n'est pas tout à fait comme les autres
puisqu'elle a été choisie pour servir de
cadre à une innovation tout à l'honneur
de la ratp
vous allez voir laquelle grâce aux
images qui vont suivre
[Musique]
alors bagatelle contre 6,38 à l'eau
patron ici ou bien s'est désolé d'être
l'otage pouvait pas venir aujourd'hui on
va patron
allo
c'est toi mon chéri
même si je suis en retard parce que ma
voiture est en panne alors j'ai pris le
métro et tu laisses clients dans métro
maintenant et bien le téléphone c'est
formidable bonjour monsieur
est-ce que je puisse venir pour une fois
mise en plis cet après midi c'est
possible écoutez je dispose de deux
heures je suis très pris cher raconte ce
soir bon je vous remercie
j'arrive madame vous avez vu qu'on a
installé un téléphone dans le métro
c'est le premier oui vous trouvez ça
bien ou pas bien c'est bien c'est assez
heureux heureux 3x bonne initiative que
l'ama et vous allez vous en servir ses
victimes pourquoi bien vous en servirez
oui pourquoi pas oui
monsieur van de putte vous êtes
directeur des services techniques du
métropolitain je crois que c'est une
grande première pour vous aujourd'hui
oui c'est une grande première c'est la
première fois que l'on installe
taxiphone public pour les u7 apparaît
ici je crois c'est à paris que vous avez
il n'a pas l'air très moderne du point
non parce que c'est un appareil
expérimental nous allons ce n'est pas
encore au public dans trois quatre jours
après ce moment c'est téléphoné au 22 à
venir par exemple on peut téléphoner à
new york par tous les intermédiaires au
but
bien sûr par à dire alors la réception
avait déjà son
et pas
nous allons la voir nous l'avions déjà
en ligne
maintenant ce sera
[Musique]